hold on sir here who's going to talk to
us about the algorithmic benefit of
correlations a couple people asked me
what am I doing here
and and in fact I think my talk is a
little different than most of the talk
in terms of the theme that I've seen but
in any case okay so I'm gonna talk about
something called algorithmic benefit of
correlated instances and they're
actually gonna be results from two
papers one was 90 CS 2015 with a Latino
and Rachel Lin and then a new paper
that's gonna be 90 CS in a couple months
which we call the fine-grained
complexity of polynomial time problems
given correlative instances so what is
this about
so before I actually start so let me
just say it sort of in a sentence what
what this is about and the idea here is
that we also like I guess a lot of the
theme of the core of the top of the
workshop is that we want to try to see
what can we do when we have problems
which are hard in the worst case so in
this paper we're talking about problems
which are essentially intractable so
it's the np-hard or conjecture to on the
average case to also be intractable in
this case we're gonna have problems
which are in polynomial time but that
strong belief that they somehow they're
stuck in order n square because of some
evidence that has been accumulated in
the recent years and the quite and this
is in worst case or even in the average
case at least in the case of this paper
and the question is okay so what do you
do which has been the theme of this
entire conference but we propose to do
the following there is the the thesis of
the whole both of these works and of
this talk is that often the problems
that you're working with they it's not
just one instance that you encounter and
that's it but there's actually many
instances and they're not independent of
each other but they might be correlated
in one way or another and if we could
find or get our hands on a bunch of
correlative instances that could be
beneficial for us to come up with faster
solutions that would break maybe this
worst-case barrier that we encounter in
both of these cases okay so that's the
story and it doesn't come out of sort of
thin air this idea but really it's sort
of his link to something that you see
that happens in cryptography
and sort of there is this example there
may be a lot of people have seen but
it's very compelling sorry repeated and
the example is for factoring integers so
that's conjectured to be a hard problem
we don't know how we have really made no
progress in many years on this problem
except for quantum but we're talking
about classical computation yet if you
were given a correlative instance and
the correlation here is extremely strong
so this is N and then there's n prime
which is the product of P where P is the
same prime up there so n s P Q and n
prime is P times Q Prime
then once you have both of these numbers
you can find the factorization very
easily just by taking a greatest common
divisor computation so it becomes a
trivial problem now this seems you know
a very untrue break very engineered
example turns out actually that it was
yes very good Mike was an MIT student
you know this a lot of other people in
the audience know the reason I say that
because no my son this isn't recorded
maybe she's really gift of pattern
matching like you might perform
extremely well in exams not
understanding anything just from pattern
entry and prime very good so in any case
this was recently exploited by paper
actually by your hand girl and other
people where they have noticed or they
saw by that in the internet many keys
actually many composite numbers the
people use let's say if they wanna use
RSA in fact are related this way so they
share prime or maybe they share they've
used the same pseudo and number
generator in order to to choose their
primes Sicily shared maybe not such a
trivial way but still a way that can be
exploited so you can actually factor the
numbers so you would say that's poor
engineering perhaps but it's still the
case that people do it and those are the
problems that we need to solve and
general you know the cryptographic ways
at least is that you have to beware of
cryptography when you're using related
keys so we at least theoretically
speaking when we write down how you're
supposed to choose keys you're supposed
to choose them in an independent way so
you don't run into these problems but
the point of that today is I want to say
is you know what the situation might not
be so rare and not just because of some
kind of mistake in the way people have
selected their keys in the cryptographic
arena and if it is not rare then we
should take advantage of it when we
design algorithms so examples might be
you know if you think about biology and
you want to learn mapping from DNA to
you know from the genotype to phenotype
then you have multiple organisms
you obviously apparently in the lab you
study about multiple organisms in order
to learn from one or about the other but
it could be even things that are much
more familiar to us or at least to me if
you think about error correcting codes
it stands to reason that on a disk you
have a lot of versions of the same file
and when there are errors you might take
advantage of the fact that you know that
these files are related to each other
when you're correct possibly you can
correct for more errors if you assume
that about your data
I mean learning I know that people have
looked at examples which are correlated
you could even think about concepts
which are correlated to each other so to
generalize all of this we'll say that
whenever the instances are derived from
one source and then of course we have to
explain what this source is but
intuitively let's say they have derived
from some one source then we should
treat them as correlated and try to
solve them together rather than
separately now since the whole I think
the of the workshop is that we want to
talk about real data or then that might
be the case that in approaching the
problems that you're approaching one
takes advantage of the fact that the
instances are related to each other and
pictorially you know we think of a
source there are these instances we
design algorithms that work on one
instance even individually one at a time
and the suggestion it is and what will
I'll try to convince you in this talk is
that this suggestion works at least in
the theoretical examples that we came up
with the suggestion is that instead of
working on one instance on its own
you should design an algorithm which
takes all these instances together and
comes up with a solution so again the
algorithm is so the thing is that that's
actually not a bad not a bad point in
order to explain the test now what I'm
doing so in other words in machine
learning do I understand at least in the
when you're training right you're given
solved examples so you're given labeled
examples and in this improves and it
enables you to come up with a good
learning but I do want to emphasize in
the context of this talk that when we
get these instances so if we want to
think of them as examples which are
labeled they're actually not labeled so
we've got a whole bunch of instances we
don't know solution to any one of them
okay
oh we know that somehow they come from
the same source so let's be a little bit
more formal so I want to think of a
model there is some sort of generating
process and we want to think in this
generating process there's something we
call primary instance and the primary
instance let's say maybe a worst case
instance that I want to solve and it has
some underlying solution it might have
many underlying solution let's a call I
guess a specific solution so we have an
instance and a solution and it could be
an average case instance the worst case
instance let's say that that's what I
care about we will say that we are there
are also auxilary instances okay
generated by this generating process and
they are correlated to the primary
instance how are they correlated it
could be depends on the problem but
let's think of it this way that these
auxiliary instances there I want through
I am and they also have hidden solutions
s1 through SN and these are distributed
a
according to some auxiliary distribution
that depends on both the primary
solution the problem we own the primary
instance and solution so in other words
I don't want to be the case that you
have an instance okay and then you
perturb it and you get a whole bunch of
other instances in a sense the intuition
is that you have an instance that
instant has some solution okay and the
auxiliary instances are such that their
solutions may be correlated to your
solution of your primary one but you
know this is a general framework all I'm
saying here is that this distribution
depends on both s and I okay so in both
s and the specific in on both the
instance in this specific solution well
a great question great question because
my next point is that's the
million-dollar question what kind of
correlation to consider so this one I
didn't say I said the word correlated
which means what it means formally me
formally just means it selected
according to a distribution that depends
on both s and I I didn't tell you how
and that will be actually problem
specific because in a sense it must be
okay why do I say that number one I
don't know what you mean by one so one
is my juice is for numb or the first
point not just a spring of this you
don't see it the input is I that's the
instance so it's it could be a graph it
could be a number you're trying to
factor it could be a set of equations
you want to satisfy okay what would be a
solution for in the graph case if you're
thinking about the clique problem it
would be some click okay if you're
thinking in the factorization number
will be the factorization and if you
think about is has a bunch of solutions
you might be a satisfying assignment to
these solutions okay so there's a eyes
Arkan on our usual instances and we are
looking to solve the problem
and an S corresponds to a solution is
that okay okay
so now let's go back to this question
what kind of correlation are we talking
about you'll become much clearer when I
start talking to concretely okay so what
kind of the correlations do we want to
consider again we're staying in the high
level we still didn't talk about an
example but I want to say that there's
sort of four kind of rules of thumb
behind what correlation models are
reasonable okay because you could say
that you could some trivialize the
problem if you don't choose the
correlation in a meaningful way so
specifically I want to make sure that
these auxiliary instances that are being
generated for you will be hard to
generate given the primary instance
alone cuz otherwise you know just take
your instance if you could take your
instance and you can generate these
things on your own there's nothing that
they're giving there's no point in
getting them from the outside source
okay
and hard here means the complexity of
solving a single instance should be hard
to do it within that complexity okay
secondly you don't want to consider a
model where you're given so many
auxilary instances that your size of
your input it's got to be so large now
that the whole thing got trivialized
okay thirdly you don't want the solution
to the your hard original primary
instance to be trivial to derive from
the solutions to easy auxilary instances
so think about auxilary instances where
essentially the new instance has a
solution it's a solution for the primary
I mean that's kind of stupid right so
again we don't want it to be a trivial
extraction of solution from this
auxiliary stuff and most importantly
which is the hardest part is that
somehow we we hope that this is these
this access to these auxiliary instances
is some approximation of reality
was very vague right in other words I'm
saying there is some process you've got
you the generator let's just think from
concretely graphs there's some process
that generated your graph okay and then
there's other graphs and we're gonna say
we're looking for three coloring of this
graph so we would want that these other
graphs there are three colorings okay
they have them are correlated to the
three coloring of the original one okay
how correlated well if there was some
process to generate this graph somehow
you want to say that this process
emulates some natural phenomena yeah
discussion so this is kind of like a
setting where that the solutions do have
semantic meaning so the the I sub J's
they're not just a function of I really
the solution means something just that
it's not like you just took that I was
the instance am i something okay that's
right that was the meaning there in the
solution I should have some yeah
absolutely so that was very important
it's a function of both s and an end I
okay all right so let's look at some
examples where this kind of methodology
actually gives you great benefit and you
will have to be the judges whether the
correlation that we assume because we're
the theoretical treatment is reasonable
or not okay but the methodology still
stands okay so I think it's and I think
it isn't important to consider what else
is available to you except the problem
at hand okay so the first so I said that
there are two plates two papers that I'm
going to talk about first one talks
about constraint satisfaction problems
so this is a very rich class of problems
captures a wide variety of problems such
as case at maximum cat three coloring
systems of equations and so forth so
constraint satisfaction problems
essentially capture almost all locally a
local local problems the problems that
are essentially the task is to solve a
whole bunch of local constraints
it's np-hard okay general to do CSPs and
be hard even to approximate them
it's conjectured to be hard on the
average there's several you know
conjectures in the literature a there's
this thing called gold rocks one way
function proposal which is based on
constraint satisfaction problems so I'll
tell you exactly what I mean by CSP okay
you're right
so what do I mean exactly by CSP here is
a definition so I'm gonna restrict
myself to talking about these kind of CS
bees so first of all there is a P which
is a predicate and this is a function
essentially it goes from D variables to
zero one so it's a boolean function D
here you think of it as a constant okay
so it takes the bits in get in tells you
0 1 and I want to think now of in
addition to P there's a graph ok
the graph is a graph that connects it's
a bipartite graph it connects sort of
inputs to outputs so you can think of
the inputs is sort of the nodes on this
graph which are labeled let say by 0 1
and then at every if you look if this
these three nodes are connected to this
guy then we label it according by
applying this predicate on the labels of
the inputs connected to it ok so the
constraints are ok so if you're given
essentially now only the output bits and
let's say you're given 0 1 1 0 and so
forth
this is specifying constraints on the
input variables so they have to be such
that for this to be 0 you know those
three variables under the predicate will
give you 0 so these are this constraint
satisfaction often regardless of whether
it's max or not people think about all
constraints being satisfied namely let's
say all ones but it's not a big
difference because we have negation so
this is same the thing is going back to
your max question is that the problem
that we often that we prove is hard is
to maximize as many as possible we're
here we're going to restrict yourself to
those instances where we know that they
all can be satisfied ok and that is a
restriction and the results I'm going to
describe out for those cases there's
still seem hard and have been
conjectured hard and that's what's this
one we go to a Conway function is is
given a function that's described this
way
okay try to invert it doesn't seem to be
much easier or any easier I think there
are some predicates which are not good
for it but essentially all almost all
predicates we don't know anything better
than general CSV but it is an
interesting question to extend this
result let's say to do a problem with
only 99 percent of these constraints to
be satisfied but did i address your
question okay so we are restricting
yourself to those class of CS space
where we do know that there all can be
satisfied and my question Q because in
your example it was max which that's
true that's true I should change that
okay so what's an instance in this case
remember I talked about instances
solutions an instance is essentially a
pair of a graph so that kind of tells
you which X is going to which wise and a
particular y what's Y it's an output
labeling so I have an output of the
labeling I know what the graphs are what
the graph is I know what that even what
the predicate is and all I want to find
out are the X is the X okay that's my
solution so X is a solution and this is
the instance okay so are these are these
hard or not as I said it's conjectured
to be hard on the average and the
parameter is here or let's say the
density the little D how many X's got
for y the density which is the ratio
between the number of output bits and
input bits the predicate and that's
gonna be the problem in the sense that
is hard today
but with correlated instances is going
to become easy so by using extra
correlation extra instances which I will
describe in a minute you can make this
problem you could have pull all the time
solutions for this problem a good so
what are the correlations okay so this
is kind of the interesting question are
these reasonable models or not first so
the first is what we call a randomly
perturb to a correlations or in in the
model as the following choose your
primary instance just like before you
know it has the graph it has a solution
and it's or it has the graph
has the why and has some hidden X X is
what we call the solution of this
instance and and auxilary instances are
defined as follows take the solution X
to the original primary guy so the
labels on X and perturb them so how do
you perturb them stake every bit then
you flip it with probability epsilon
from 1 to 0 or 0 to 1 and now you know
you sort of plug in this new X and you
get a new Y so this is each one of these
is generated exactly that this way each
time a new perturbation of the X gives
you a new instance yeah
why is remembering that graph y is the
labeling on the output bits and X is the
labeling on database so I'm given Y and
I'm wondering which X made Y happen okay
so this is this random perturbation
model another model is the following so
now with my problem is just as usual I'm
given the G Y G y 1g y q gy whatever and
I'm looking for X I'm not giving the X's
another model that one consider is it is
yeah if you can't clauses yeah you're
not changing the clauses you're only
changing whether they're 1 or 0 I'm
changing the variables not the closet so
the clauses are the same size the same
you asking me to see the graph each time
yes that's right that's right that's
right
I'm not changing the predicate you can
actually have different predicates on
each bit that's not going to make a
different same results but the graph
we're not changing it will be more
general if you had different graphs for
each instance ok so the second model is
the followings in a is the same except
in addition to be being given these Gy 1
Gy 2 Gy 3 and so forth somebody is very
considerate of you and gives you also
the differences between X in X 1 X and X
2 X and X 3 so in other words there's an
X the causes this thing the Y and
there's an X 1 causes at y 1 and X 2 cos
Y 2
you are looking for X in somebody tells
you you know what I'm not gonna tell you
what X is or what X is 1 is and so forth
but I'll tell you the difference between
X
x1 x and x2 and so forth it seems like a
lot okay in fact it is extremely useful
but I want to say that in my opinion
it's natural as well
why is it natural again thinking as a
cryptographer then often we can tamper
okay so we have a key we don't know what
it is but possibly we have the ability
to tamper let's say to go to a bitten
and flip it there's another bit and flip
it okay and and ask now what the problem
become an easier what I'm doing here is
not that I'm not allowing you to tamper
I'm not allowing you to say that you
would like to take X and get an X if ik
x1 which is a tampering of X all I'm
saying is if somebody randomly changed X
they will tell you where the changes
were made but they're not telling you if
it went from 1 to 0 or 0 to 1 okay yes I
just think of it as a constant yeah
between 0 and half yeah
now the thing about this model I don't
think it's that on you it's that
impossible to think that we know such
that we would know that for something
that comes up not in nature or and
naturally but in any case the reason why
we introduced it is because it's a
stepping stone to get the results so we
will first solve it in this model and
then we'll show how to approximate this
model even in this case so it's the way
the algorithm algorithms will work is
that they in some sense will approximate
the differences and then using the
differences we'll be able to solve the
original X okay so I I what are the
results so the first result is that
given when random primary instance so
even the original one was a random
primary instance and auxilary instances
which are randomly perturb the way I
described there is an algorithm defines
the solution the set of us satisfies
almost all of the constraints so you can
do this in polynomial time now you're
not going to find the original
necessarily all of X but you'll find
something which is close to X so when I
say satisfies almost all of the
constraints X prime can be shown to be
closed in Hamming distance okay I'm sort
of gonna go faster because I think the
second half is actually much more
interesting but I want to still say what
we can get okay and I see
it's almost all ready for question you
would think you could get all of them so
I did not reveal many solution so I
guess X is sort of unique X is not
unique you're right not necessarily but
one can show that the thing that you'll
find will be close to that X yeah and
I'll talk about how in a minute what if
you you're a primary instance was worst
case okay so it turns out that if he was
worst case and you consider that the
second model the one where not only that
it's a perturbation but somebody even
tells you the differences between X and
X 1 on X and X 2 X and 3 then you can
actually find X prime this satisfies all
so not just most ok and furthermore you
can do it for a worst case so in some
sense you've made your life easier right
by giving these known differences for
the algorithm you've made it hard by
making it work on a worst case instance
but the making easier was you know
helped more than the making hard and you
can solve for a worst case instance okay
it's the strain satisfaction problem
it's actually sort of more general than
what I'm saying it doesn't D in
everything I was saying was a constant
so like he's you know in the picture
there were three X is going to a Y but
you can extend this actually you know to
locality like or to login and it's tight
so you can also show that there are
predicates with some already see log n
which are np-hard so it's below log in
okay
like what is the policy of measure of
distance between my measure is hamming
distance I don't think I have a result I
mean the result is for having distance
okay so it's not a general a general
result it's a good question in the
context of the next stop in the next
half of my talk I will come up and the
third thing that I want to say is that
how many in extra instances do we need
in these two theorems order login what
if you had only one single instance but
auxiliary instance so you had your
constraint satisfaction problem somebody
gave you a perturbed version another
instance it turns out even there you can
do something you can find a solution but
that's only for a restricted class of
piece of predicate so it's the kind you
might with predicate was I was taking X
1 X 3 and X 7 and doing a predicate on
it
when these predicates are sort of highly
correlated with one of their one of
their inputs okay so P of X 1 X 2 X 3 I
think it's always excellent or highly
correlated to X 1 a then you can
actually solve the problem if you only
got one extra could be could be 1 okay
so what's the idea before we go I just
give you a word like like a two minute
idea so what's the idea so the idea is
the following so let's say that we have
a particular input so it's a particular
graph a particular Y particular
predicate okay and we want to find X so
let's think about it what's happening
here so this is let's say the original X
ok and we don't know what it is this
we're trying to figure out this is the
Y's and then somebody also gives me a
white bra y1 and y2 and so forth this is
essentially a y1 which is obtained by
perturbing X doing the graph doing the
predicate okay so I said and n let's say
we're in this just give you the idea we
even know the differences so we know the
deltas between X and X 1 X and X 2 and
so forth so what does that mean it means
that if you sort of restrict yourself in
a particular bit
location we're trying to figure out what
would the exes are right let's look at a
particular bit location in the output so
this is the bit this bit location in Y
in y1 and y2 and so forth we know that
this bit location is the result of
applying the predicate on three bits
which we're trying to figure out and
similarly this guy is a result of a
truck of applying the predicate on three
bits we're trying to figure out so what
do you can observe that Finn's would
take an order login instances that it's
easy to see that eventually that we will
actually see all all possible a
differences so in particular we'll see
also all possible 3 carbonate
differences for this bit location and
that suggests that we could think of a
another encoding for X so I'm trying to
figure out what X is okay what do I have
what do I know no so here's a new
encoding for X essentially it's the
value of the predicate which I get
because it's the Y and X + Shift + I get
this for lots of shifts and if I get it
for all for all shifts this is an
alternative essentially encoding of X
which I can which means that if it was
unique I could figure out what X is y
just know where no possibilities how
many bits are we talking about here D
that's 2 to the deeds no problem
great so but who says it will be unique
it doesn't necessarily have to be unique
so this your encoding doesn't
necessarily pin X down right that's
right that's right but you know for some
predicate as I said it's not unique but
you can show up a lemma that's
essentially that for all predicates
regardless of what it is there is some
unique linear subspace which will
contain all the differences between X
and X prime as long as X and X prime
have the same essentially are encoded
their encoding is the same so what that
means what
find any one of the exes no no the
problem is that they I need to paste all
them together so this is what to invite
those three bits those two bits but it
has to be consistent so we can write
down a system of linear equations and
solve them okay and that's in depth the
algorithm now what if you wanted to
address the case where I didn't know the
differences this kind of heavily
dependent on the differences the
strategy will be that we want to
approximate these differences how do we
approximate them well what we know now
you know just sort of in a word or we
know now if we get back to this picture
okay now I don't know the difference but
what I do know is that if this flipped
let's say if we went from zero to one it
must be the one of these three bits
flipped I don't know which but again
given enough like order login instances
I'll do some voting and I'll be able to
get some an idea it's not so simple
because you get these noisy linear
equations at the end because even this
idea is just a guess and you have to
solve a system of linear equations but
it's okay well deal with it somehow
alright so what are so let's so I think
that's all I want to say about this
paper a let's do quick reflection before
we get to the next one one thing one may
say as they say the adversary that maybe
this whole thing work because this was a
randomized please be you know like you
know there what the theorem that I did
theorem one maybe when you talk about
average hardness you know CSP is not is
not is not it's not hard but that's
probably not correct because you can
actually get correlation didn't help you
just because of that because essentially
you can take a PCP instance of something
and be hard and kind of encode it this
way and still show that it will succumb
to correlation so it's not the inherent
easiness of what we started with the
second thing is that you could talk
about is how much correlation do you
actually need and it's sort of non
monotonic because if they were
completely correlated it's all the XS
were the same well complete oh come the
anti Co completely correlated that
that's useless
you know the same problem I can repeat
it as much as I like it's not gonna help
so there is some combination here or
that they have to be correlated but not
too much for sort of the sweet spot for
this to work and sort of an interesting
question to study where that happens but
maybe the most interesting question
which will lead us to the next paper is
OKC ESPYs
you know these intractable problems
who's gonna give me these correlated
instances a I don't know maybe they will
but let's think of something a bit more
natural in particular how about problems
in P so what we shown is to take an
intractable problem whether we prove
this np-complete or we just don't know
the solution make it tractable but how
about problems that we actually solve
all the time in polynomial time is there
any benefit to this idea of correlated
instances and if so which one should we
look at so the idea is that we won't of
course look at polynomial time problems
where we have some confidence in the
fact that we've sort of reached the best
of our abilities and try to improve
there so the place that we're going to
look at are these problems that come so
let me tell you which problems okay so
i'll numerate three problems and then
explain why we chose those so the first
problem is going to be the longest
common subsequence problem so here
you're getting two strings okay over
some alphabet and you're asking what is
the longest subsequence which is not
consecutive necessarily which is common
to both okay the second is the edit
distance you've gotten two strings you
know x and y to go you will you know
that there's a way to go from x and y by
inserts deletes and change of characters
and you'd like that know what is the
minimum number of these edits okay maybe
to find them even that's the Edit
problem so this is a max problem there's
a min problem
I gave examples here but you all know
you know what this means in the third
one sorry there's four you can think of
what longest common subsequence not just
two strings but K strings okay sometimes
people call this multiple sequence
alignment a and the the last one is
something called dynamic time or working
distance and the idea is the following
again let's think of it as a few two
strings just like in the longest common
subsequence but now when you're
traversing them okay you sort of go
walking in this one and you're walking
that one you want
you want to burst them possibly in
different speeds so you might go you had
you have a finger here and a finger here
and you might be go faster on the top
one that in the bottom what you're
looking for is the minimum number of
mismatches introvert reversal where at
each step either one or both strings
moves forward so you're sort of making
steps going forward and you were looking
to see when you're gonna get a mismatch
okay so this is essentially a very
natural measure I don't want to get too
much into it but it's a very natural
measure when you stop comparing to
videos and you want to know over there
the same one isn't in the faster speed
than the other or audio let's talk about
all of these things are they're all sort
of similarity measures between strings
okay
and in what strobe are all these
similarity measures is that they sort of
depend on the size of the set of
matching pairs so if you think about
matching pairs like a and a a here and a
here that's a pair or be hit and B here
it's a pair and the number of matching
pairs will kind of dominate the the
complexity it will be a crucial part of
the complexity of solving these problems
specific but again this is just you know
people interested look at the paper
there's a way to generalize all of these
measures that I talked about in
something called a similarity measure
and the algorithm that I'll describe
works for anything that lays this
generalization so what's known okay so
we know for these problems for all of
these problems we know the dynamic
programming you know is the solution
order N squared right you talk good but
what's interesting and why we chose this
is that we know that any improvement
let's say to get to N squared minus four
shape anything up here will imply that
there's a whole bunch of other problems
which will be improved this is this fine
grained complexity theory where they
show equivalence these fine grade
equivalences between problems that if
any one of them you can beat you can
beat the rest we also know that just it
will if you can beat it it contradicts
some sort of complexity assumption I
don't know what to make of that you know
but it is what it is and the next thing
that I want to say that we know is that
you
find these examples in contrast maybe
with the constraint satisfaction example
that I gave which was a sort of one-way
function constructive cryptographers in
the world world
the right source a longest comment
subsequence or multiple sequence aligns
is really what they do when they lied
the inline DNA sequences sort of in
evolutionary studies so these are
natural problems so again remember that
our whole thing was that we wanted to
find natural problems where we can get
lots of instances which are correlated
to each other at least these are natural
and now the question is can we take
advantage of the correlation of
correlations to solve these problems
okay so what correlations I haven't said
these are going to be different than
what we did in the previous part of the
talk so here's the model there gonna be
two models I'll talk about one of them
am I out of time no well okay so one of
them is the following
and this is a very strict model and then
we will relax it so here the idea is
this the primary instance and let's just
look at longest common subsequence you
can essentially see what it would mean
for the other models so the longest
common subsequence we have a pair of
strings that's my primary instance right
and let's say the solution I bought I
here should be asked but in any case
what is the solution the solution would
be the location of the longest common
subsequence to X&Y right the auxiliary
instances are going to be defined as
follows
take a random pair X x1 and y1 okay so
these are random strings have nothing to
do with your original X Y except for the
following which is what your force and
that is let's say that if you look at
the locations where the longest common
subsequence was in X&Y those locations
in x1 y1 also have matching strings so
here so let's say this is X and this is
y let's say that B be a B it matches
here this is the longest common
subsequence okay then in those a in that
location the second the third the fourth
and the fifth will match exactly what's
in the first second third and six okay
and that's true for this pair of
instances for this pair for this pair so
these are the new this is my observing
instance x1 y1 x2 y2 x3 what
and so forth okay notice that it's not
the same string these are different
strings it's just the locations are so
one thing to notice is that the fact
that the line it's not the case that
these locations are and also the longest
common substring for these so they have
matches in those but if you know if you
saw the longest common subsequence on
this it doesn't give you the longest let
me get to that in a minute okay but cuz
I want to first relax it
that's beautiful question we don't
generate them because if I could
generate them I you know the whole point
of this and it's good thank you for the
question because I think probably half
the audience is under this
misunderstanding I the only I'd get it
from God or whatever you like no I get
it from some supreme authority okay
there is this X Y that I want to solve
okay somehow I can also find these
extras with this promise the reason I
wrote it like with the reason I wrote
generate is because I want to and I want
to have a formal definition of the
generating process there is some process
that generated this way now they only
give me the exponent okay all right and
what's a relaxed one a relaxed one is
essentially the same except now I don't
force those equalities I just want that
the locations where the longest common
subsequence appears an x and y will
contain a match in the auxiliary ones
with probability greater than better
than random so where is if you think
here it was really a went to a B to B
and so forth in the relaxed one these
strings are more luck you know and there
is a higher chance of being a than B
yeah more than 50% okay so there is some
reason there is some correlation but
they're not I'm not forcing equality
okay so now you asked a very good
question does this come up that is where
I can prove the results okay
it is no I mean I think we should all be
honest okay and I don't think it's
unlikely that you can get let's say DNA
sequences that have some correlation is
it exactly this is it in the
neighborhood of that I don't know in
fact let's put it this way there's
theories and those practitioners right
and whenever you talk to theorists they
say ah you require too much there's
never such sequences so I actually went
and talked to a whole bunch of people in
the broad describe the time they said
you know what let's try it so they are
not so negative do they know their data
better than we do
so in order to answer that I think you
have to run it on on real data and see
probably it's not exactly this moral
this doesn't mean that the algorithmic
approached it I'm gonna show in a minute
will not make some kind of a dent in the
data they do have this is the paper I
described which which one was some
sequencing a bit multiple one which is
gonna be think of like for the
improvement which I haven't said what it
is yet okay so the improvement is gonna
be the following we're gonna show some
quadratic algorithms we're gonna beat
this order N squared okay and how many
auxilary instances order log in okay so
let's just give you the idea and then
we'll be we'll be done I think so the
main theorem just to be more explicit is
that you can be you can get order n log
in with a strict model where I'm forcing
the equality and order n to the 1 plus D
where D is left and once we're beating
the N squared in the more relaxed model
the relaxed model is where the I don't
force equality in the auxilary strings
but just they are more likely have less
epsilon of equality okay can you do half
this can you do 1 over Sigma sighs plus
epsilon and whatever the alphabet size
but yeah the alphabet is just constants
but right now it's 2 it happens
if you had a toast or let it out for
that one yeah that's fine it's for Genoa
off a bit I didn't say to tolerate one
part of this yes yes this is nothing to
do with it
you know so it will equal it so the way
that I do it I say toss a coin bias half
plus epsilon if it comes up heads I make
it the same if it comes up tails I make
it anything else in the alphabet there's
already information if you make it agree
a quarter of it more than quarter of the
time yeah is obviously better than
random so one quarter process no I mean
the I have to think about it but I have
to think about how the probabilistic
analysis works it's not a very deep one
so it's an easy calculation but I'd
rather do it offline I don't think I
don't think so it's not something that
is actually trying okay so what's the
idea so here's the algorithms here's the
algorithm so let's say we have a primary
X in a NY okay and the length here of
the string is six right and it sticks
and the auxilary let's say are these
pairs pair what a pair pair pair so the
first thing we do is the following the
main idea is that we're going to define
a new a new longest comment subsequence
wrong with a different alphabet okay
what is a different alphabet so consider
this so I'm going to consider the
following vectors of characters so let's
take the first position okay in X so
this is in the X and in all the axillary
axis so this is a be a be a that's the
first position of the x's okay so I'm
taking essentially all the first
characters and all the x's and that's my
first vector okay
then I'll take the second position you
know be a a be B so essentially for each
position in the string that first the
second to third up to the end I take I
make these vectors which we can think of
as essentially new characters in an
extended string what's the extended
string this is his first letter this is
second letter as third letter and so
forth I do this for the XS and I do this
for the Y's so now I have a new instance
it has this bigger alphabet for
character one character and so forth now
notice the following
that if you look at matches okay just
for the example I did I didn't explain
why but in a minute it will be clear so
if you look for matches now by matches I
mean before an A and an A anywhere
that's a match over a pair or being a be
anywhere that's a match so the same way
here a match means a character here
which is equal to a character down here
these are exactly going to be the
matches so I think I have this guy goes
to here they're the same right so
there's be AAA BBB AAA BBB and support
the matches actually occur exactly where
the longest common subsequence was so
it's like the 2nd 3rd 4th 2nd 3rd 4th
and 5th in the 1st in the X and 1 2 3 &
6 in the Y what why that is WH why
coincidence obviously if the reason is
because when you have order log in
auxilary instances the probability that
anything not in the longest common
subsequence
results in in a matching pair in this
extended string is low so by doing what
we've done okay we've made it that if
there is a match at all between the
extended X and X 10 is why it's gonna
occur in something that was in the
longest common subsequence which means
algorithmically that all we need to do
now is not so fancy longest common
sequence we just have to find matches so
because so the intuition is if they you
found a match it's part of the longest
common sequence so just look for matches
by matches I mean if you just thought
about the ordinary strings in a in a
name meeting each other except in this
new alphabet that's all if they does
happen they're already part of the
longest common subsequence okay so the
strategy is to find these match vectors
in the top and the bottom and how do you
do it you use hashing what kind of
hashing well if you think about it I
could take everything that's an X and
just hash them and I do it for the guys
and why and they will throw onto the
same into the same bucket and that's why
it's n log n because I'm hashing in of
these vectors right whereas many vectors
as locations in the original character
each one of them is log in long what
about the relaxed model okay that and
then I will be done
will this work for the relaxed model no
because in the relaxed model the pairs
of the longest comes have sequins are
only guaranteed to match with height
higher probability than the others but
not more than that so essentially the
idea of a matching doesn't even exist
anymore they're not guaranteed to be the
same but there is some guarantee so if
you look at the vectors up and the
vectors down okay
in the location where there was the
longest common subsequence then they
will be closer together so you look at
those two vectors are gonna be different
but they're gonna write so in the end up
up in the top and the bottom but there
will be sort of closer than if they were
just chosen completely at random so this
suggests that the thing is to try to
find essentially in close or neighbors
so we want to essentially run an
algorithm which will allow me to show
which vectors are closer to each other
and in fact in sort of Hamming distance
in which dimension would log in right
because I had logged in instances and
each character in the alphabet had log
in coordinates into it okay and I just
want to now take and take take one of
these extended characters in X and look
at who's closest to it in the Y's and
the one that's closest to it will be
essentially the guy which will be what I
correspond my guess at a match in in the
longest common subsequence in the
primary X&Y
so essentially we use an algorithm it's
there's some recent algorithm that we
use which achieves this running time and
notice what's going on here okay and in
fact so we're shaving off it's not N
squared anymore their algorithm works
for it finds the nearest neighbors
whenever the dimension is order log in
which is exactly our case and we're done
so obviously in the relaxed model we're
taking more time this is not in log in
but it still beats the quadratic bound
model it was I went looking for matching
characters and the way I'll do it is by
hashing
so I just want to say a word I thought
Roby was gonna be here but he's not is
that there is another month it's not the
only thing with some other correlation
model for edits so what would be a
natural thing for edits forget
everything I said so far
so for edits and I mean that's a natural
thing for edits would be is that you say
x and y then x prime and y prime they
use the same edit sequence so to go from
X to R you have to delete the third
character insert 7th they change a whole
bunch of things you do the same to an X
prime an arbitrary X prime you do the
same okay so one control order n log in
for this correlation model and it's very
related to some work it's related in
very related knotting to connect or
anything else but there is a work on
smooth analysis for it by Robbie Cartman
and Donny where they were trying to
figure out if there's something they can
say about the Edit problem which is
better than order N squared so what they
said is we want to think of smooth
analysis now one day what they meant by
smooth analysis is the following they
said let's take an x and a y who's
longer this comes it and although it and
let's think about where their longest
comment subsequence is okay and now we
will we will change we will perturb
because it smooth analysis will perturb
x and y at at will okay except for where
the longest comment subsequence is we we
do the same with the same changes so if
there was an A and a see they're both
turning to a B okay and then they say
this is sort of smooth or at least it's
a perturbation of the original one and
they show that in fact for this model
they can come up with a linear time
approximation for it for minimum edit
okay so what is the similarity it was
completely different I mean they are
perturbing something we are given an
instance okay also their perturbation is
not something they can really do because
we're how do they know where the longest
common subsequences so it's also a
little bit in this realm of magic so
they're not getting additional
correlated instances but where I see the
similarity is that it's interesting that
the same model came up their
perturbation model was the same model
that we essentially use here for
correlations it's you know it to be
interpreted so there's lots of open
problems you know I think the main
problem is whether for example what
we've done
any bearing on real sequences a or find
other correlations in nature where speed
ups can be obtained and rigorously
analyzed what else so I guess I conclude
that I believe that correlations are
available it's really up for us to take
advantage of them so the challenge is
how do you take advantage of them how do
you define them formally and possibly as
was the theme a little bit in this
workshop as I understand it the best may
be the only way that we'll know what
correlations are out there is to try
this so I'm not sure this is what you
mean but it has occurred to me that one
way to get correlated instances is with
in any dynamic programming algorithm so
if you think about dynamic program right
I've got some local function and the way
we do it is we already solve the
previous ones longer so the new one so
in some sense what this is saying maybe
instead of solving them you take the
whole neighborhood you solve it together
because you know that they're you even
know what the correlation is between
them because you are the one that's how
you define your problem certain if
that's where you're getting at but I
don't see though as it is now is the
dynamic programming at all yeah
in reality when you wind up to know if
your instances are correlated or not is
there any way of checking I mean because
well in the factoring example you do
know the correlation and you do know
they're correlated you may know because
they you may assume that there's a
limited amount of randomness in the
world or everybody's using the same
source of randomness and that's how your
instances were generated so even right
in evolutionary studies they have all
kinds of models of how evolution
proceeds and they are they correct I
think in a sense if you run an algorithm
it works a with a gives you some
evidence it's a good question I don't
know yes double simple sequence
evolution models right like the Kimura
model for example which is extremely
simple probabilistic so for those would
you get correlated instances if you I
think I think you wouldn't it would be
the right thing to do is to analyze
which would be wonder so by the way the
multiple sequence alignment in according
to this model will get you order a KN
log in which is much better than what we
do which is n to the K but it's this
model so I'm saying it would be one the
right thing to do going forward is to
take one of these models and try to see
if we couldn't the correlations that
have been defined there but if I were to
pick an auxiliary instance and call that
that's great so that's a so that's
another correlation model which one
could could analyze we didn't do it but
I think that's a great open direction
even in the CSV so why so the suggestion
here is rather than X is related to X 1
X with a 2 X 2 X 2 X 3
you take X you perturb it to get X 1 you
take Suwannee perturb to get X 2 and so
forth if you think evolutionary let's
say these things progress in time or
something I agree with you that's a
different model and then you have to get
different algorithms I guess if you were
able to measure the correlation between
problem instances like I said I guess it
wouldn't be the original problem it's by
itself may not be because instances that
are correlated with the current problem
you might be able to solve it just
because you can verify doesn't mean that
you can generate he was just saying that
whether you can verify given data
whether a certain model correlations how
do you get any approximation better time
dimension rather than going for exact
and and get it'll be satisfied with the
n plus 1 plus D just try to get an
approximation linear time series yeah we
didn't you assume that the graph remains
fixed right in what happens if you
actually in our little perturbations in
the graph as well I think it was
important for the analysis that the
graphs are the same graph but the amount
of difference that's right that's right
so we would just looked at either all
the same or completely arbitrary graphs
but if they're related obviously you can
get something right yes and what I'm
thinking of is you know verification
problems which is one of the main
applications of SAP of India for also
kind of CSP type solving technology
right very often you actually have sort
of minor variations of the same
underlying hardware or software
structure about which you want to verify
these might not be identical across but
if they're not identical they might be
very very closely related and so there
might be another kind of that's actually
great so you won't have to do all the
work to verify from scratch but you can
that's it and my understanding we have
somebody here is an expert on this but
in in real world verification at least
of software what really happens is that
you have salt and that if you have to
solve millions and millions of instances
that structurally resemble each other to
the point where it makes sense to tune
you a solver an existing solver to
handle them more effectively now your
approach is very different right you
would see if they are correlated enough
we might be able to take a look at all
of them together and solve them all in
one go and everything much much longer
right so in fact I think that's the only
take main takeaway that it leads to very
different algorithms I mean the
algorithm that we did here it's nothing
to do they never programming in a CSP is
nothing to do with that's overs yep this
might be like there's like you have
several related programs and they all
the same but closer but they all have
the same bug in pen so you know it makes
it maybe easier to find bugs but I think
power that's he's not saying this
particular algorithm is just solution I
guess other settings where correlate
instances like any of these Bayesian
optimization
make a little change is very close
related just a conceptual no no the
conception level but you know this whole
um I think the conceptual level here is
not so divorced from actually trying get
your hands dirty and specific problems